un cambio en la presencia militar de
francia mali parís ha comenzado el
proceso de la cesión del control de su
base en entidad los soldados de la
misión de la onu el malí y el mismo
ejército nacional se harán cargo de la
base en los próximos días la fuerza
misma de la onu entidad está formada por
1.300 soldados de guinea y chad otros
400 soldados del ejército maliense
también mantendrán su presencia la base
militar final es una de las tres bases
que el ejército francés tiene en el
norte de mali además los franceses
también tienen previsto abandonar otras
dos de tombuctú y tessalit anunciada en
junio en francia la reorganización forma
parte del plan de reducción gradual de
la operación marcan su misión
antiterrorista en el sahel como parte de
ese plan el contingente francés de la
misión se reducirá de los más de 5000
soldados actuales a menos de tres mil en
2023 la medida se da en medio del
aumento de tensiones entre francia y
malí en septiembre el primer ministro
interino de malí acusó y de abandonar el
país a lo que francia respondió con
dureza con emanuel macrón acusando al
gobierno militar de malí de no tener
legitimidad además mal ya ha
intensificado su cooperación militar con
rusia lo que ha generado preocupación en
parís por la posibilidad de que moscú
intente llenar el vacío de las tropas
francesas